Spirometry is a test of how
well your lungs are working,
by measuring how fast
and how much air you
can breathe in and out.
Normally as you breathe in,
or inhale, air moves freely
through your
trachea, or windpipe,
then through large
tubes called bronchi,
smaller tubes called
the bronchioles,
and finally into tiny
sacs called alveoli.
Small blood vessels,
called capillaries,
surround your alveoli.
Oxygen from the air you breathe
passes into your capillaries.
Then carbon dioxide
from your body
passes out of your
capillaries into an alveolus.
You get rid of
the carbon dioxide
when you breathe out, or exhale.
Diseases such as
asthma, bronchitis,
and pulmonary fibrosis
narrow your bronchioles,
reducing the amount of
air going into your lungs.
And diseases such as
lung cancer and emphysema
damage your alveoli,
reducing the amount of oxygen
in your blood.
These diseases can make it
hard for you to breathe.
Your doctor may recommend
a spirometry test
to identify a disease
in your lungs,
check the severity of your
existing lung disease,
or to determine if the
medications you take
are helping.
During the test,
your caregiver will
use a device called
a spirometer.
A spirometer is a
machine that measures
the air you breathe out.
Before you take the
spectrometry test,
you will sit in a comfortable
chair with your feet
flat on the floor.
If you have dentures, you
may be asked to remove them.
For best results,
you will be advised
to follow your caregiver's
instructions exactly.
To start, you will
raise your head and chin
so that you can breathe easily.
Next, you will place
a clip on your nose
to prevent air from coming
out of your nostrils.
Then, you'll take a deep breath,
filling your lungs completely
with air, and hold it.
You will place the spirometer's
mouthpiece between your teeth
and tightly seal your
lips surround it.
Finally, you will blast
the air out of your lungs
as hard and as fast as you
can, continuing to breathe out
until your caregiver
tells you to stop.
If you are an adult, you will
blow for at least six seconds.
Children 10 years old and under
will blow for three seconds.
You will need to perform the
spirometry test correctly
three times to get
accurate results.